from the ages now investigators a
teacher who stole tax dollars set aside
to help students during the covid-19
pandemic has avoided jail time this is
Andrea Fuentes Soto she was in court
yesterday only the eight news now
investigators were there as well she
pleaded guilty to felony theft and
through that plea deal she is now on
probation in court she declined to make
any statement and offered no apology
Ms Fuentes do you have anything you'd
like to say no
Fuentes Soto is one of three Charter
School Employees charged in the theft
ring this is a story the 8 news now
investigators first broke and you can
read more about it on our website
8newsnow.com